فنحن نمثل في هذه المرحله 5 دول فقط ولكن
في المستقبل سيتوسع البنك ليضم عددا اكبر
من دول الامم المتحده
[موسيقى]
ما يثير قلقنا هو الوضع غير المستقر في
الاسواق العالميه وتارجح اسعار الطاقه
والموارد الطبيعيه ناهيك عن القروض
الكبيره لدى العديد من الدول كل ذلك يؤثر
على ديناميكيه نهوض اقتصاداتنا ويخلق عدم
الاستقرار ولذلك فان بريكس ستلجا اكثر الى
استخدام مواردها واحتياطاتها الداخليه
[موسيقى]
سياسه الضغوط والعقوبات الغربيه بالروسيا
ومحاوله عزلها واضعاف اقتصادها منحت دفعه
لهذا التقارب الزعيم الصيني بعث برساله
صريحه على ان بلاده تدعم نهج بوتين
[موسيقى]
البنوك بتاعهم الاموال والاستثمار نتاع
المجموعه نتاع البريك تخلي الجزائر اقوى
اقوى اقتصاديا وقوه الحقيقيه ليست لا
القوه العسكريه ولا القوه الحقيقيه
بالنسبه للشعوب هي القوه الاقتصاديه